[Musique]
l'année dernière on avait fait une
première édition sur les lumières
c'était le thème est cette deuxième
édition elle est sûre au delà des
limites
j'ai eu l'occasion de rencontrer des
personnes et je me suis rendu compte
qu'il ya deux types de population il ya
des personnes qui qui restent cantonnés
dans leur zone de confort il ya des
personnes qui font des choix différents
et ses choix exige de sortir du chemin
connu donc au delà limite pour moi c'est
repoussé les limites du connu et
décloisonnée décloisonner entre des
disciplines pour moi je t'ai dit
s'appeler c'est créer des ponts dans
paris 7 les et au delà des limites
une fois qu'on a enlevé les pombas en
repousse ses limites mais tous enfants
dans les profils il ya un peu de tout en
fait le premier c'est un scientifique
qui est aussi philosophe et à thierry
marx qui est un chef étoilé mais c'est
vrai un quelqu'un qui s'est fait par lui
même c'est un parcours personnel et ya
raphaël haumont francs belges suisses et
c'est un chimiste mais qui est passionné
par la matière donc en fait il ya des
chercheurs entrepreneurs artistes et des
aventuriers comme avec ghislain bardot
pour un des deux pôles les 12 minutes
c'était un conseil d'alsace en stage
donc c'est l'entreprise avec qui on
travaille qui fait le coaching les
intervenants parce qu'ils ont remarqué
que sur une durée de 12 minutes la vidéo
sur youtube a plus de chance d'être
écoutés entendus
donc ça c'est des statistiques eux ils
ont enfin atteint et je trouve que ça
donne du dynamisme c'est à dire qu'on a
gardé le même timing par rapport à
l'année dernière sauf qu'on a douze
intervenants lieu de 10 et je pense que
c'est même un challenge pour les
intervenants faire le même discours
entre en 12 minutes au lieu de 15 cd
dire qu'il faut qu'ils aillent au coeur
du message et ça c'est quelque chose
qu'on recherche
le public était absorbé il ya eu des
moments de rire et des moments très
forts de concentration et ça pour moi
c'est une belle mesure
je suis très très heureuse parce que
quand on la vit la salle on s'est dit
c'est un challenge est ce qu'on va voir
réussir à remplir la salle pour la
deuxième édition
c'était le cas c'est complet et puis
beaucoup de lieux des icônes hector et
tout ça qui nous ont suivis qui ont
parlé de l'événement qui ont qui ont qui
sont venus assister à nos réunions
mensuelles avec les et connecteurs les
partenaires on en a 19 cette année il y
en a d'autres qui arrivent je pense que
c'est un un succès vous j'en suis
convaincu je ne pense pas